[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara
halallweg guten Abend und willkommen
Norbert Lehmann ist auch wieder dabei
für den Sport einen schön guten Abend
auch von mir schauen wir auf die
Nachrichtenthemen von
heute alles auf dem Prüfstand nach der
Haushaltssperre wird heftig darüber
gestritten wie man am besten zu einer
tragbaren Lösung kommtung der
Hoffnung in Tel Aviv offenbar sollen 50
hamasgeiseln freigelassen werden während
einer mehrtägigen Waffenruhe im Nahen
Osten und Deutsche unter Druck nach der
Niederlage gegen die Türkei will die
Fußballnationalmannschaft heute Abend
gegen Österreich unbedingt
gewinnen der Finanzminister zieht nach
dem Urteil des Bundesverfassungsgerichts
die Notbremse weil mindestens 60
Milliarden Euro im Bundeshaus haalt
fehlen hat Lindner eine weitgehende
Haushaltssperre verhängt heißt alles was
verabschiedet ist und gezahlt werden
muss wird bezahlt aber alle anderen
Pläne der Ministerien liegen erstmal auf
Eis bis die Regierung eine Lösung findet
wie die aussehen könnte zeigt Christian
Volk die erste Option weniger Geld
ausgeben das will vor allem die FDP
würde bedeuten sparen möglicherweise bei
Investitionen für Klimaschutz oder
Sozialleistungen Möglichkeit 2wei mehr
Geld einnehmen ein erster Schritt das
Ende der reduzierten Mehrwertsteuer in
der Gastronomie ein geschätztes Plus von
3,5 Milliarden Euro pro Jahr dritte
Option ein neues Sondervermögen
verabschieden also ein Weg um neben dem
Haushalt Schulden zu machen so wie bei
der Bundeswehr dafür braucht es aber die
Opposition und eine zwei Drittel
Mehrheit in Bundestag und
Bundesrat die vierte Möglichkeit eine
Reform der Schuldenbremse die wurde
ursprünglich eingeführt um nachfolgenden
Generationen keine Schuldenberge zu
vererben von SPD und Grünen heißt es
aber sie sei zu Star Bremse langfristige
Investitionen aus für eine Änderung
braucht es aber auch hier eine zwei
Drittel Mehrheit in den beiden
Parlamentskammern Option 5 eine
Haushaltsnotlage erklären damit wollen
SPD und Grüne die Schuldenbremse
zeitweise aussetzen so ist das schon mal
wegen cor und der Energiekrise passiert
es ist aber strittig ob eine solche
Notsituation aktuell
vorliegt weil das ganze so komplex ist
gab es im Bundestag dazu heute eine
Anhörung von
Sachverständigen nach ihrer Einschätzung
ist möglicherweise nicht nur der Klima
und
transformationsfond verfassungswidrig
sondern auch noch andere wie der
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfond der
finanziert z.B die strompreisbremsen für
braucher und auch den hat das
Finanzministerium heute vorsorglich
gesperrt es fehlt also viel Geld und es
herrscht große Unsicherheit dter
Ferber auf diesem Acker bei Magdeburg
will Intel in seine Chipfabrik
investieren Milliarden Fördergelder sind
zugesagt unsicher ist das jetzt
Angesicht des 60 Milliarden
euroolchs dass diese Gelder auch nicht
bei 60 Milliarden netto stehen bleiben
sondern weit mehr Kapital Hebeln also
dass der Verlust für die Volkswirtschaft
wenn jetzt nicht investiert werden würde
umso größer ist anders als die Grünen
will die FDP jetzt aber nicht mehr
investieren sondern sparen
Schuldenbremse das ist die
inflationsbremse und es ist zu erwarten
dass die moderat restriktiv angelegte
Fiskalpolitik nach gewissen
höchstrichterlichen Entscheidungen
vielleicht sogar noch ein bisschen
weniger moderat und noch ein bisschen
Rest restktiver im nächsten Jahr sein
wird wie sparen wo sparen die SPD würde
am liebsten mehr Schulden machen die
Schuldenbremse lockern nur regiert sie
nicht allein die Dinge werden jetzt sehr
sorgfältig diskutiert alles andere wäre
eine Missachtung der Entscheidung des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts und deshalb
geht hier Sorgfalt vor alles andere und
das heißt auch dass nicht jeder gleich
das was ihm gerade auf dem herzenlicht
rausplappern muss der Bundestag hörte
heute online Experten z Thema auch die
sind sich uneinig Vorsicht lautet ein
Ratschlag momentan sind die Planung
nicht seit dass der Bundeshaushalt für
das nächste Jahr aufgestellt werden kann
zunächst einmal bedeutet dieses
Verfassungsgerichtsurteil Verunsicherung
der Investoren denn viele Themen stehen
jetzt in Zweifel beispielsweise der
Kompromiss zur Stromsteuer zur
Entlastung auch der energieintensiven in
diesem Paket das ist alles zweifelhaft
geworden eine komplizierte Haushaltslage
viel Unsicherheit die
MT da es darf jetzt nichts mehr
ausgegeben werden ohne dass das
Bundesfinanzministerium noch mal drauf
guckt damit keine Verpflichtung für die
Zukunft eingegangen werden die
möglicherweise nicht mehr gedeckt sind
der Finanzminister hat schon eine Sperre
für den sogenannten
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfond Energie
verhängt die energiepreisbremse soll
aber
weitergelten fragen wir nach in Berlin
und an der Börse zuerst zu shakunal la
benergy Haushaltssperre Milliardenlöcher
wie handlungsfähig ist die Regierung im
Moment noch ja Sperre ist natürlich erst
einmal ein Wort das ja dramatisch klingt
und es ist tatsächlich politisch auch
ein deutlicher Einschnitt aber das heißt
nicht dass die Bundesregierung jetzt
gänzlich vom Geld abgeschnitten ist
Christian Lindner hat ja vor allem
Ausgaben gestoppt die für das kommende
Jahr zugesagt werden könnten noch die
sind aber nicht komplett ausgeschlossen
es kann Ausnahmen geben wenn ein
Ministerium sagt wir brauchen dringend
Geld für ein bestimmtes Projekt kann es
das beim Bundesfinanzminister beantragen
und wenn es dann wirklich dringlich
genug ist können dann auch Gelder
freigegeben werden also man könnte
bildlich sagen der Finanzminister hat
jetzt erst einmal ein Schloss vor die
Haushaltskasse gehängt bis klar ist wie
groß das Loch in der Haushaltsplanung
ist denn das konnten die Experten ja
heute auch noch nicht abschließend
beantworten man muss erstmal gucken gibt
es noch weitere Sondervermögen die
betroffen sind wie viele Milliarden
fehlen dann am Ende ähm also
handlungsunfähig ist die Regierung
momentan nicht aber es gibt auch
momentan keine Planungssicherheit und
und das hat auch Auswirkungen mm darüber
reden wir jetzt mit Frank betmann ein
Teil der gesperrten Gelder wären in die
Wirtschaft geflossen was bedeutet die
Situation für die Unternehmen ja es
klang ja eben schon an vor allem
Unsicherheit konjunkturell stehen die
meisten Betriebe ohnehin vor schwierigen
Zeiten jetzt drohen also auch
Subventionen wegzufallen wo genau darum
wird nun schwer gerungen werden müssen
die drohenden Haushaltskürzungen könnten
aber besonders heftige Auswirkungen auf
die die ostdeutsche Wirtschaft haben
nach heutigem Stand sein nach Meinung
von wirtschaftsstaatssekretär Michael
Kellner weder der Wiederaufbau der
Solarindustrie in Ostdeutschland noch
die Ansiedlung der Chipfabriken in
Dresden und machdeburg gesichert für die
beiden Halbleiter Großprojekte hat die
Bundesregierung auch das haben wir ja
schon gehört milliardenubvention
versprochen ihre Finanzierung hängt nun
aber genauso in der Luft wie die über 12
Milliarden Euro zum Ausbau der
Bahninfrastruktur Medienberichten
zufolge steht bereits ein erster
Streckenabschnitt der geplanten
Generalsanierung auf der Kippe vielen
Dank nach Berlin und Frankfurt danke
schakun la benery und Frank
betmann der Haushalt gesperrt die
Regierung in Nöten dazu haben wir ein ZF
Spezial ins Programm genommen und das
kommt gleich hier im Anschluss an diese
heuteesendung wie raus aus der
Haushaltskrise alles steht auf dem
Prüfstand auch die geplante Verdopplung
der Militärhilfe für die Ukraine auf 8
Milliarden ist noch nicht beschlossen
ungeachtet dessen versprach
Verteidigungsminister Pistorius heute in
Kiev Hilfen in Höhe von 1,3 Milliarden
Euro zu 100% durchfinanziert hieß es aus
seinem Ministerium bei seinem
Überraschungsbesuch gedachte Pistorius
der Menschen die bei den proeuropäischen
Protesten auf dem maidanplatz im Zentrum
von Kiev vor 10 Jahren getötet wurden
Tim
Krüger der deutsche
Verteidigungsminister ist am Morgen
einer der ersten der Blumen für die
Toten der maidandemonstrationen
niederlegt die proeuropäischen Proteste
von damals wirkten bis heute nach so
Boris Pistorius mutige Menschen aller
aller Altersgruppen sind auf die Straße
gegangen haben für Freiheit für
Annährung in Europa
äh protestiert und demonstriert und sind
haben dafür mit dem Leben bezahlt die
Proteste begannen nachdem der damalige
ukrainische Präsident der kremmeltreue
janukovics das asoziierungsabkommen mit
der EU platzen ließ mehr als 100
Menschen starben durch die teils
gewaltsamen Übergriffe der
Sicherheitskräfte am Ende floh der
Präsident nach Russland Ukrain und
Ukrainerinnen gedachten heute der
Toten das was heute in unserem Land
passiert ist ein Zeichen dafür dass ihr
Heldentum fortgesetzt wird und wir
weiterkämpfen für die Unabhängigkeit
unseres
Landes ich fühle nur Trauer um meine
Freunde hier kamen meine Freunde ums
Leben und jetzt kämpfen einige an der
Front Verteidigungsminister Boris
Pistorius sagte der Ukraine auch weitere
1,3 Milliarden Euro Militärhilfe zu
darin enthalten diee wichtigen ires
tflugabwehrsysteme ich bin mir ziemlich
sicher dass das ihnen und ihrem Kampf
gegen die russische Aggression helfen
wird in den vergangenen Tagen haben die
Angriffe wieder zugenommen die Ukraine
könnte vor einem weiteren schwierigen
Winter
stehen nach Israel im Norden des
Gazastreifens wird weiter gekämpft die
israelische Armee forderte die
Bevölkerung in den großen Städten erneut
auf in den Süden zu fliehen in Tel Aviv
harren viele Menschen seit Stunden aus
weil sie auf die Freilassung der Geiseln
hoffen die in der Gewalt der Hamas sind
zur Stunde berät dort die israelische
Regierung Michael bwerunge in Tel Aviv
was hören sie gibt es jetzt tatsächlich
eine Einigung Feuerpause gegen
Freilassung der Geiseln
ja zumindest ein paar Plätze an dieser
für die Geiseln von Gaser symbolisch
gedeckten Tafel werden nicht länger frei
bleiben müssen in diesen Minuten tritt
hinter mir auf der anderen Straßenseite
im Verteidigungsministerium das gesamte
israelische Kabinett zusammen um formal
seine Zustimmung zu dem ausgehandelten
geiseldeal zu geben wie der genau
aussieht das ist noch immer nicht ganz
klar es ist in der die Rede von einer
viertägigen Feuerpause in dieser Zeit
sollen etwa 50 bis 80 vor allem Kinder
und Frauen ausgetauscht werden im
Verhältnis 1:3 gegen palästinensische
Gefangene in israelischen Gefängnissen
das soll etwa an einem Tag 10 bis 15
Personen jeweils ausgetauscht werden
damit die Garantie gegeben wird dass der
Waffenstillstand auch eingehalten wird
allerdings ist diese Zahl alles noch
nicht genau bestätigt wenn das alles
funktioniert dann könnte das allerdings
die blaup
für einen weiteren gefangenaustausch
sein der dann in den nächsten Tagen
danach stattfinden könnte vielen Dank
für diese Informationen aus Tel Aviv
Michael
bwerunge zurück nach Deutschland etwa
5inhalb Millionen muslibe leben hier wie
werden sie behandelt wie gut sind sie
integriert und wo stehen Sie wenn es um
Antisemitismus geht solche Fragen
bespricht derzeit die Islamkonferenz das
Forum für den Austausch zwischen zwis
dem deutschen Staat und den Muslimen wie
viel noch zu tun ist für ein
harmonisches Zusammenleben zeigt Susanna
Santina mit einem Beispiel aus
Berlin weil sie eine liberale Moschee
führt wo Frauen und Männer gemeinsam
beten können wir se dann atesch von
Islamisten und türkischen Nationalisten
bedroht sie wird immer streng bewacht
auch ihre Moschee atesch kritisiert dass
die Bundesregierung mit Verbänden wie
der türkischen Dip zusammenarbeitet
diese Verbände haben meiner Ansicht nach
eine Stimmung verbreitet in Deutschland
dass im liberale Muslime nicht sicher
sein können unter anderem weil Leute wie
Erdogan mit seinem langen Arm nämlich
der ditip hier die Deutungshoheit über
den Islam an sich gerissen hat und diese
Leute gefährden uns Verbände wie dietip
deren rund 1000 Imame aus der Türkei
nach Deutschland kommen sollen mehr in
die Pflicht genommen werden sagte die
bundesinnenministerin heute in Berlin
sie hätten auch eine Verantwortung es
ist auch an den islamischen
Gemeinschaften und Verbänden in
Deutschland sich laut und deutlich gegen
Antisemitismus auszusprechen und den
Terrorismus zu verurteilen
Antisemitismus und muslimfeindlichkeit
in Deutschland stehen bei der
Islamkonferenz auf der Tagesordnung der
eskalierte der ostkonflikt hat zudem das
Thema Antisemitismus unter Muslimen in
den Fokus gerückt immer wieder wurden
auf proalästiner Demos islamistische und
antisemitische Parolen skandiert und die
Zahl antisemitischer Vorfälle hat
deutlich zugenommen beim jüdischen
Fußballverein makabi Frankfurt haben
immer mehr Eltern Angst ihre Kinder ins
Training zu schicken sie müssen sich nur
die Social Media Posts die Hassparolen
die Hassreden sie müssen sich nur das
anschauen was auf deutschen Straßen
heutzutage möglich ist die
Bundesregierung müsse mehr mit Liberalen
Muslimen zusammenarbeiten sagt seran
atesch und die Mame in Deutschland
sollten vor allem hier ausgebildet
werden wer mit Behörden zu tun hat stößt
oft an Grenzen knappe Öffnungszeiten
warten auf Ansprechpartner viel
Bürokratie bei wenig Personal
helfen soll KI künstliche Intelligenz
etwa in Heidelberg hat man fragen ans
Bürgeramt kann man die online stellen in
einem Chat Beispiel Reisepass was kostet
es sich einen ausstellen zu lassen das
KI gestützte System liefert die Antwort
solche digitalen Hilfen in der
Verwaltung auszubauen ist ein Ziel der
Bundesregierung Jan Frederik Fischer
undis
Huben zusammenfassen was auf diesen 100
Seiten eine Aufgabe die Stunden dauert
doch dank kiassistent F13 brauchen sie
in Stuttgarts Landesverwaltung dafür nur
noch wenige Sekunden es unterstützt m
dabei in komplexen Themen schnellen
Einstieg zu zu erhaltenen schnellen
Überblick und somit Zeit auch zu sparen
das Besondere Nutzer können jederzeit
nachvollziehen woher das Programm seine
Informationen nimmt hinterlegt sind nur
ausgewählte Quellen der Verwaltung
dahinter steckt die deutsche KI Schmiede
Alf Alpha unsere Mission ist wie können
wir die komplexesten und kritischen
Wertschöpfungsprozesse der Welt
unterstützen also im Gesundheitswesen
klar Verwaltung haben wir gesehen aber
auch für große Finanzinstitute doch in
Deutschland ist man KI gegenüber oft
skeptisch und so wirbt badenwürttbergs
Ministerpräsident selbst für mehr Mut
die öffentliche Verwaltung aber auch
renommierte Unternehmen müssen sich
einfach stärker öffnen auch für Start
damit die auch schneller hochkmen Alf
Alpha haben die Aufträge des Landes
geholfen das Unternehmen bekam von
deutschen Investoren zuletzt eine halbe
Milliarde US-Dollar viel für Deutschland
im weltweiten Vergleich wenig wir haben
auch die Situation dass die Wettbewerber
internationalen Vergleich deutlich mehr
Kapital zur Verfügung bestestellt
bekommen haben 10 Milliarden allein open
ai doch es sei noch nicht zu spät das
Potenzial für KI made in Germany sei da
jetzt komme es darauf an berührungs
Ängste abzubauen damit die Technologie
in Deutschlands Büros Alltag werden kann
nach New York dort wurden die
international Emys verliehen ein
wichtiger Fernseh und streamingpreis in
der Kategorie beste Dramaserie hat die
deutsche Netflix Produktion die Kaiserin
gewonnen hier die jubelnde Autorin
Katharina Eisen das Historiendrama
erzählt von der Romanze zwischen
Kaiserin Elisabeth besser bekannt als
Sissi und Kaiser Franz Josef samt
Verschwörungen und Machtkämpfen am
österreichisch ungarischen
Hof und jetzt fußballnbert gleich das
letzte Testspiel für die DFB Männer in
Wien gegen Österreich ja und da stehen
Trainer Julian nagzmann und sein Team
ganz schön unter Druck nach der
Niederlage am Samstag gegen die Türkei
muss ein Sieg her sonst war das wohl mit
der vom neuen Bundestrainer
anfangsentfachten Aufbruchstimmung fürs
em Jahr
2024 Jochen Breier in Wien ja was wird
was muss nagelsmann heute Abend anders
machen was muss er anders machen er muss
gewinnen ich glaube so einfach bzw so
kompliziert ist das am Ende denn als
Deutscher Bundestrainer sollte man ein
Nachbarschaftsduell gegen Österreich
indem es ja auch um sehr viel Prestige
geht möglichst gewinnen als Julian
nagelsmann aber vor allem braucht der
deutsche Fußball ein Erfolgserlebnis am
Ende dieses Jahres dieses Jahr 2023 war
ja als das Jahr ausgerufen worden indem
der deutsche Fußball die Fans
zurückgewinnen wollte die Fans sollten
wieder sich begeistern für die
Mannschaft die wir hier sehen wie sie
ankommt im Ernst Hel Stadion nach diesem
debakkel in Qatar das hat wie wir wissen
nicht geklappt letzten Samstag die
Niederlage gegen die Türkei und sollte
das heute auch noch mal schief gehen
gegen Österreich gegen rangnig das wäre
vorsichtig formuliert fatal aber der
Bundestrainer hat einen Plan wir gehen
schwer davon aus dass Kai harard wieder
hinten links spielen wird und es könnte
gut sein dass Josua Kimmich womöglich
aus dem Zentrum auf die Bank rotiert
also das ist ein paar Veränderungen im
deutschen Team gibt wir melden uns um
20:25 Uhr hier aus Wien danke Jochen bis
gleich dann 20 der 24 Mannschaften für
die EM stehen fest gestern Abend hat
sich auch Titelverteidiger Italien
qualifiziert durch ein mühsames 0:0
gegen die
Ukraine die Erlösung für Italien nach
einer zitterpe über 95 Minuten die
Squadra Azura ließ in diesem Spiel viele
Chancen ungenutzt wie hier Federico Cesa
und wäre in der Nachspielzeit dann fast
für seine fehlende Effizienz bestraft
worden der Ukrainer mutrück kommt im
Strafraum zu Fall aber der mögliche
meteter Pfiff bleibt aus und auch der
Videos Schiedsrichter greift nicht ein
das tourlose Remis reicht Italien für
die EM
Qualifikation wir sind stolz auf unsere
Leistung in der Kabine haben wir uns in
den Armen gelegen es ist eine große
Befreiung jetzt sind wir da wo wir
hingehören aber auch die Ukraine durfte
sich im Stadion von Bayern Leverkusen
zurecht feiern lassen und hat noch die
Chance sich über die Playoffs im März
das EM Ticket zu
sichern das war's V Sport danke schön
gerne wenn zwei eine Reise tun soweit
ist es zwar noch nicht aber die
Vorbereitungen für Pitt und paulle
laufen auf Hochtouren geboren und
aufgewachsen in Berlin dürfen die beiden
pandazwillinge im Dezember zurück in die
Heimat ihrer Eltern nach China denn
jetzt wären sie soweit dort Familien zu
gründen und die Welt mit weiteren
sympathischen Pandas zu be
und davon kann es ja eigentlich nicht
genug
geben vorsicht vor glatten Straßen heute
Nacht davor waren gleich Katja horneffer
und erklärt auch wie es weitergeht
wettermäßig Marietta slomker begrüßt sie
im heute journal in der Halbzeitpause
gegen 9:30 uh hier geht's jetzt weiter
mit dem ZF Spezial einen schönen Abend
und bis morgen wenn Sie mögen auf
[Musik]
Wiedersehen
guten Abend turbulent geht's weiter
heute Nacht sinkt die Schneefallgrenze
in den östlichen Mittelgebirgen zum Teil
unter 500 m und morgen Schneid es hier
am Alpenrand noch weiter am Nachmittag
kommen dann neue Regenwolken von der
Nordseeküste heran glatt kann es heute
Nacht auch in Norddeutschland werden da
ist der Himmel zum Teil klar und es
bildet sich Nebel die Temperaturen
sinken auf + 4° am oberrein und bis -5°
an der Oder und morgen liegen die
Höchsttemperaturen im Osten um den
Gefrierpunkt im Westen knapp drüber und
das wird ein freundlicher Mittwoch nach
Nebel zeigt sich häufig die Sonne am
Alpenrand gibt's noch etwas Schneeregen
und dann ändert sich langsam was erstmal
ist es noch mild und es fällt Regen aber
zum Ende der Woche wird aus dem Regen
mehr und mehr Schnee und es kommen nicht
nur Regen und Schneefälle heran sondern
es wird auch richtig stürmisch vor allen
Dingen an der Küste das sehen Sie auf
unseren Aussichten ganz schön am Freitag
dreht der Wind schon mehr auf nördliche
Richtungen und am Samstag liegen dann
die Höchsttemperaturen deutschlandweit
nur noch bei 0 bis 7° und wenn Sie sich
fragen wie viel Schnee denn wohl liegen
bleibt im Flachland das müssen wir noch
abwarten aber in den Mittelgebirgen sind
es Samstagabend 10 bis 20 am Alpenrand
bis 50 cm guten Abend